bonjour à tous une vidéo un petit peu
particulière aujourd'hui puisque je vais
la faire pour réagir un peu à chauds à
une actualité brûlante celle des ondes
gravitationnelles donc vous n'avez
probablement pas échappé à la nouvelle
on vient d'annoncer pour la première
fois la découverte donc gravitationnelle
donc ce que je voudrais faire dans cette
vidéo s'expliquer un petit peu
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est et puis
comment on a fait pour les détecter et
pourquoi c'est important
vous savez une vidéo qui est un petit
peu plus informelle un petit peu moins
léché que d'habitude mais voilà ces
histoires de tester aussi un nouveau
format alors pour comprendre ce que
c'est que les ondes gravitationnelles en
fait il faut repartir de la manière dont
on conçoit la force de gravité par la
force de gravité quand on la prend par
exemple au lycée on la prend avec la loi
de newton donc c'est une loi qui donne
l'intensité de la force de gravité qui
s'exerce entre deux objets massifs et
cette force
elle dépend des masses des objets elle
est proportionnelle au mas des objets et
puis elle dépend comme l' inverse du
carré de leurs distances alors c'est pas
très important de retenir la forme
exacte de la loi qui donne cette force
ce qui est intéressant de constater avec
cette force là c'est qu'en fait tel que
l'avait proposé newton c'est une force
qui se transmet de manière instantanée
c'est à dire que si jamais on a deux
matches comme ça et puis qu'on imagine
que soudainement l'une des masses
disparaît ou bien change subitement de
trajectoire dans la vision de newton en
fait la force se transmet instantanément
où l'information que la force a changé
se transmet instantanément à l'autre
masse alors ça c'est quand même
conceptuellement un petit peu étrange
faut quand même remarquer que à part
cette petite bizarrerie conceptuel en
fait la loi de newton c'est quand même
un truc qui marche vachement bien elle a
été formulée il ya peut-être presque 350
ans et en fait on continue de l'utiliser
tous les jours elle permet de prédire la
trajectoire des boulets de canon et
aussi la trajectoire des astres par
exemple est un savant quelque chose qui
marche formidablement bien
mais il ya quand même cette petite
bizarrerie conceptuel qui est que si on
croit cette loi il ya une espèce
d'information qui voyagent
instantanément quand la force se modifie
alors si on regarde en fait il ya une
autre force qui quand on la prend au
lycée se comporte un petit peu la même
manière c'est la force électrostatique
donc la force électrostatique elle est
donnée par la loi de coulon qui en fait
ressemble énormément à la loi de newton
en fait c'est juste l'adaptation sauf
qu'au lieu d'avoir des masses on à
décharge électrique et vous savez
peut-être que la force électrostatique
en fait on l'a ensuite remplacé par
quelque chose de plus efficace le plus
riche qui l électromagnétisme donc là
forces électrostatiques elle avait ce
même défaut qu'à la loi de newton de
supposer que plus ou moins à
l'information se transmet instantanément
à distance et ça ça a été guérie par
l'électromagnétisme puisque
l'électromagnétisme en fait quelque
chose de plus complexe
je veux pas vous faire un cours sur
l'électromagnétisme l'électromagnétisme
en gros prend en compte le fait que
l'information prend un certain temps à
voyager notamment sous la forme d' onde
électromagnétique qui voyagent à la
vitesse de la lumière fait la lumière
c'est une onde électromagnétique et donc
l'électromagnétisme qui quelque part
remplacé complète la force
électrostatique de coulon en fête permet
de résoudre ce paradoxe alors naïvement
comme ça on pourrait penser que il va se
passer la même chose avec la gravité que
ce qui s'est passé avec
l'électrostatique c'est à dire qu'on va
remplacer la loi de newton par un truc
qui est plus riche plus compliqué et qui
fait intervenir des ondes qui peuvent se
propager en fait la réalité c'est quand
même quelque chose de plus compliqué que
cela la loi de newton en fait elle a été
supplanté si on peut dire en 1915 par la
théorie de la relativité générale
d'einstein est en fait la théorie de la
relativité générale c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est beaucoup beaucoup
plus compliqué que l'éléctromagnétisme
la relativité générale c'est pas juste
l'électromagnétisme adaptée à la gravité
dans ses quelque chose de beaucoup plus
compliquée qui s'y posent notamment que
la force de gravité provient de la
courbure de l'espace temps
alors ça c'est très bien et il faut
savoir que la théorie de la relativité
générale aussi complexe et mystérieuse
qu'elle soit en fait elle a été vérifiée
expérimentalement de plein de manières
et rentrent en fait elle fait un certain
nombre de prédiction qui sont
différentes des prédictions que faisait
la théorie de newton et la plupart de
ces prédictions en fait ont été vérifiés
expérimentalement on peut citer par
exemple le fait que les astres enfin les
corps massif des vies la lumière donc ça
a été vérifiée on peut citer les trous
noirs
on peut citer le big bang l'expansion de
l'univers
le fait que par exemple dans un champ
gravitationnel intense le temps ne
s'écoule pas de la même manière bon
voilà tout ça c'est des prédictions de
la relativité générale
alors ce qui est un petit peu étonnant
c'est que la relativité générale il ya
un domaine où on n'a pas réussi encore à
faire de validation expérimentale forte
c'est le domaine où les courbure de
l'espace et du temps sont faibles alors
en fait ce qui se passe c'est quand on
prend la relativité générale et si
jamais on l'apprend dans un domaine où
les courbures sont faibles en fait elle
se simplifie beaucoup et on retrouve une
théorie qui ressemble un peu à
l'électromagnétisme c'est à dire on
retrouve une théorie dans lesquelles il
ya des ondes des ondes qui se propage et
donc c'est ça qu'on appelle les ondes
gravitationnelles donc les ondes
gravitationnelles
en gros c'est ce qui se passe quand on
fait de la relativité générale dans un
espace temps qui est peu courbé ça peut
paraître un peu bizarre mais il faut
savoir que l'espace temps autour de nous
en fait il est peu courbé finalement la
relativité générale on aime bien les
situations extrêmes comme les trous
noirs et le truc comme ça mais il faut
bien voir que la quasi totalité de
l'univers est en fait un truc pas du
tout aux extrêmes en fait très peu
courbé donc voilà donc dans un espace
temps qui est très peu courbé la théorie
de la relativité générale prédit qu' on
doit avoir des ondes gravitationnelles
qu'est ce que c'est des ondes
gravitationnelles parce que c'est quand
même important de bien visualiser ce
qu'on veut ce que ça veut dire
on a dit la relativité générale elle
décrit la force de gravité au moyen de
la courbure de l'espace-temps donc une
onde gravitationnelle qui provient la
relativité générale en fait c'est une
onde de déformation l'espace-temps peut
en quelque sorte dire une onde de cours
de saison elles ont une structure assez
particulière je vais essayer vous
représentez en fait quand une onde
gravitationnelle avance et passe à
travers un objet elle fait ça
ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
quand une gravitationnelle passe à
travers un objet elle va dilater l'objet
dans un sens et le contracter dans
l'autre et ensuite leur contractée dans
ce sens là et dilatés dans le sens
opposé
voilà le nom gravitationnelle quelques
qui se propage ça fait ça alors un truc
important pour savoir comment on peut
faire pour détecter des ondes
gravitationnelles
c'est déjà de savoir qu'est-ce qui en
émet alors à priori à peu près n'importe
quoi peut émettre des ondes
gravitationnelles
le problème c'est que les ondes
gravitationnelles c'est un truc qui est
fabuleusement faible et donc si on a va
avoir une chance de détecter des ondes
gravitationnelles
il faut se placer dans un cas on en
train de regarder des événements assez
violents notamment ce qui émet des ondes
gravitationnelles ses décors massif qui
sont fortement accélérées dans l'univers
la situation qu'on connaît le mieux de
corps massif qui sont très fortement
accéléré c'est quand on a deux étoiles
qui se tourne autour n'avaient pas
parfois un binaire et notamment les cas
les plus extrêmes c'est quand ces
étoiles sont très très très lourde et
notamment par exemple des étoiles à
neutrons qui sont en quelque sorte des
cadavres des toiles voire carrément des
trous noirs et contre caen des étoiles à
neutrons ou des trous noirs se tournent
autour en fait ils sont très massif et
très accéléré et donc ils émettent des
ondes gravitationnelles
alors c'est quand même pas suffisant
parce que dans le temps normal de leur
rotation c'est encore trop faible pour
qu'on puisse le détecter le seul truc
qu'on a un l'espoir de détecter
c'est le moment où les là on est très
proche de la collision
donc quand on a deux astres qui se
tourne autour et qui sont très massif et
qui tourne très vite et qui sont au
moment où ils vont rentrer en collision
c'est là qu'il ya une bouffée donc
gravitationnelle qui est plus élevé que
la plupart du temps et ses ondes saison
là qu'on a une chance de détecter
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je me dis les ondes
gravitationnelles en fait débat on en a
jamais détectés la seule preuve dont on
dispose c'est une preuve indirecte
en fait il ya deux astronomes qui un
jour ont repéré un de ces deux
séminaires ils ont remarqué que ce
séminaire perdait de l'énergie est en
fait une fois tout vérifier le seul
moyen de justifier que ce binaire puisse
perdre de l'énergie
c'est d'imaginer qu'il émet des ondes
gravitationnelles et que en quelque
sorte il rayonne une partie de son
énergie sous la forme d'ondés
gravitationnelles
donc ça ça a été en quelque sorte une
preuve indirecte de l'existence des
ondes gravitationnelles
et d'ailleurs les deux astronomes ont eu
le prix nobel pour cette découverte mais
ça a ce quelque chose d'un direct c'est
à dire visiblement on a un phénomène et
on ne peut l'expliquer qu'avec des ondes
gravitationnelles mais on n'a pas
directement vous les ondes
gravitationnelles donc toute la question
c'est de savoir comment est ce qu'on
peut vraiment directement détecter ces
ondes de déformation l'espace temps
alors en fait ce qui est très compliqué
c'est que ces ondes
elle provoque des déformations qui sont
ridiculement petit
en gros pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur si on prenait une barre qui
fait un mètre de long et que cette barre
soit traversée par une ligne
gravitationnelle la longueur de la barre
varierait d'à peu près 10 puissance
moins 19 m donc un truc vert une
longueur qui est quand même
fabuleusement plus petit que la taille
d'un atome
donc ça veut dire que détecter des
variations de longueur à cause des ondes
gravitationnelles c'est ça semble
quasiment impossible
la méthode qu'on utilise pour avoir un
espoir de les voir quand même c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'interférométrie en
l'interférométrie c'est une méthode
optique qui permet de repérer des très
petites variations de distance le
principe c'est le suivant on prend un
laser et puis on sait par le faisceau
laser en deux et on l'envoie dans deux
directions qui sont à 90 degrés et puis
on fait parcourir à chacun des deux
faisceaux une certaine distance on place
un miroir et ensuite on les faire
revenir
et quand les deux faisceaux revienne et
se rencontre on obtient ce qu'on appelle
une figure d'interférences qui est un
truc un petit peu caractéristique on
voit des franges lumineuse qui est
alternent avec des franges chambre et
l'ours qui est assez amusant c'est que
si on prend ce dispositif donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut faire par
exemple en général en en tp de physique
je pense peut-être en première ou en
deuxième année à l'université
c'est quelque chose de pas très très
compliqué à la fois laser et des miroirs
on peut se rendre compte que si on
déplace un des miroirs d'une toute
petite distance par exemple 100
nanomètres
ça se voit tout de suite sur la figure
d'interférences parce que la figure
bouge donc en fait l'interférométrie
c'est une méthode qui permet de mesurer
des variations de distance de manière
très très fine très précises
le seul problème c'est que là je viens
de vous dire en gros avec un montage
interférométrique comme ça on peut très
facilement repérer des variations de
distance de 100 nanomètres ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est que si
on a une barre d'un mètre elle va pas
varier de 100 nanomètres sous l'effet
d'une gravitationnelle à elle va varier
de 10 - 10 nanomètres
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
espérer quand même la rhdp à la solution
qu'on a trouvé c'est de faire un
interféromètre géant donc est ce que
c'est un interféromètre géant mais c'est
le même principe que celui je viens de
vous décrire ça on fera un faisceau
laser on sépare en deux sauf qu'au lieu
de lui faire faire un mètre avant de
rencontrer un miroir et de revenir on
lui fait faire 5 km donc ça c'est le
principe des interféromètres géant donc
il y en a essentiellement de enfin il ya
deux collaborations qui ont été montées
pour soi des interféromètres de ce type
là il ya la collaboration virgo qui est
plutôt européenne et puis la
collaboration ligocki est plutôt
américaine et donc le principe c'est
qu'on en voit comme ça à faisceau laser
dans deux tubes qui font cinq kilomètres
de long qui sont qui sont vides en fait
tout pour objet de faire le vide dans le
tube on les fait revenir et on les fait
interférer elle en fait on se contente
de même pas de faire ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait pour gagner encore un peu
plus de distance
ils font plusieurs allers-retours dans
le tube crois qu'ils font quelque chose
comme 75 aller retour est donc là on
récupère une figure d'interférences et
l'espoir c'est si jamais il ya une ombre
gravitationnelle qui passe et bien cette
figure d'interférences
elles doivent un petit peu bougé un truc
un truc le king et sk mais ça peut être
la signature du fait qu'il ya des ondes
gravitationnelles qu'ils ont alors la
première collaboration league ou en fait
elle a commencé à fonctionner en 2002 et
à la fonctionné jusqu'en 2010 est donc
enfin là on a tout dit on est en train
d'essayer de détecter un truc avant tout
petit et donc il avait été calculé que
étant donné la sensibilité du montage
et puis étant donné la probabilité que
dans une
lyon proche de nous il est effectivement
un binaire qui sont en train d'entrer en
collision
on avait peut-être une chance sur dix de
détecter des ondes gravitationnelles
avec ce montage
le grand changement qu'il a eu c'est que
entre 2010 et 2015 en fait le montage de
l'expérience lio a été beaucoup
améliorée notamment la sensibilité et du
fait de l'amélioration de la sensibilité
les gens qui font tourner cette manip
avait estimé qu'il devait voir beaucoup
plus d'événements et qu' il avait
normalement une probabilité de voir
plusieurs événements chaque année parce
que le montage est devenu beaucoup plus
sensible et l'expérience donc ligot je
crois qu'on l'appelle advanced ligo ou
extended vigo je sais exactement
elle a commencé à tourner en septembre
2015 est donc visiblement ils ont eu du
bol parce que ça très vite marché et qu'
ils ont repéré quelque chose alors il ya
une grande question là dedans c'est
comment est ce qu'on est sûr que ce
qu'on a repérés correspondent bien à des
ondes gravitationnelles
alors il ya plusieurs choses qu'on fait
le truc le plus important c'est qu'en
fait les gens de 10 go ils sont malins
ils n'ont pas construit un
interféromètre gens non construites 2 il
y en a qu'un louisiane et l'autre qui
est dans l'état de washington
un peu plus au nord et donc quand un
événement donc gravitationnelle est
supposé arriver on est censé le voir sur
les deux interféromètre avec juste un
tout petit décalage temporel qui
correspond au temps qu'il faut à l'undd
pour voyager d'un détecteur à l'autre et
donc dans le cas précis dont on parle
ça a été un des moyens de vérifier que
ce qu'on avait été pas triste du bruit
ou une fluctuation ou un truc un truc
faut c'est le fait que l'événement a
vraiment été observées sur les deux
détecteurs et à partir de la
caractéristique de l'événement on peut
remonter en gros au scénario de ce qui
est en train de se passer dans le
binaire qui est en train de générer les
ondes gravitationnelles met donc là
visiblement ils ont pu déduire que
binaire qui était à l'origine de ce
cette bouffe aidante gravitationnelle
qui a été détecté en fait il était formé
par deux trous noirs qui étaient en
train de se tourner autour et qui de
fusionner en fait que c'est vraiment le
moment qui précède la fusion convoi et
que ces trous noirs avaient des masses
qui correspondait à quelques dizaines de
fois la taille du soleil
donc voilà donc il semblerait que pour
la première fois on est vraiment
détecter directement des ondes
gravitationnelles
alors la question maintenant c'est
est-ce que ça c'est important
alors oui c'est clairement important et
je dire pour tout de suite
évacué la question du prix nobel si
effectivement il s'avère que que c'est
vrai et que l'équipe a détecté les ondes
gravitationnelles il ya aucun doute
qu'un jour ils auront le prix nobel
peut-être pas ça n'est pas très bien ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que les ondes
gravitationnelles c'était vraiment ans
quelle que soit la pièce manquante au
puzzle de la relativité générale je vous
ai dit la relativité générale faire
certain nombre de prédiction toutes ces
prédictions avaient été vérifiées sauf
les ondes gravitationnelles là c'est
vraiment la dernière pièce du puzzle en
quelque sorte on peut hein peut comparer
ça à la découverte qui a eu en 2012 du
boson de higgs le boson de higgs c'était
vraiment la pièce manquante qui manquait
à la physique des particules faire qu'on
avait la théorie tout dans la théorie
avait été vérifié dans les accélérateurs
de particules
sauf ce truc qui était le boson de higgs
donc là on est vraiment un peu dans le
même genre de situation mine de rien moi
je trouve que ce genre de découverte
quelque part c'est toujours un petit peu
triste
c'est à dire qu'on a une prédictions
théoriques et puis on construit une
manip énorme je veux dire du point de
vue expérimental fait que la main truc
de folie
et puis bah au final on arrive à
vérifier la théorie douce et donc c'est
super mais du point de vue de la
physique c'est quelque part presque un
peu fade
il n'y a pas de surprise fois et ça
m'avait fait un peu le même sentiment au
moment de
la découverte du boson de xc r je
m'étais dit bon ben ok c'est bien on l'a
trouvée mais c'est pas voilà c'est un
peu triste parce que de temps en temps
quand on fait la physique on aime bien
être surpris
on dit souvent que le truc la phrase la
plus intéressante quand on fait de la
science c'est pas eureka j'ai trouvé ces
tiens ça c'est bizarre et voilà donc là
visiblement rien de bizarre n'a été
trouvée tout semble marcher comme sur
des roulettes
donc oui clairement c'est vraiment une
très grande découverte mais voilà ça
laisse toujours un petit peu sur la fin
ce genre de découverte parce que
finalement on a fait que vérifier la
théorie et c'est quand même toujours
sympa quand les expériences amène des
choses bizarres qui viennent ensuite
stimuler un peu le cerveau des tertiales
donc voilà donc j'espère que cette
petite histoire vous aura permis d'y
voir un peu plus clair sur cette
question des ondes gravitationnelles
on verra d'autres façons dans les mois à
venir il y aura probablement des choses
nouvelles qui seront annoncées parce que
si le détecteur ligot est si sensible
que ça il est vraisemblable que au cours
des mois qui viennent il puisse
identifier détecter d'autres événements
donc de toutes façons on saura très vite
si c'est quelque chose de 2
de fausses qui a l'air quand même assez
peu probable ou bien si maintenant en
fait on est capable de détecter vraiment
régulièrement des ondes
gravitationnelles voilà écouter merci
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo c'était un
format un petit peu différent vous aurez
remarqué quelque chose de pas très
léchée quelque chose d'un peu plus
informelle j'espère que ça vous a plu
peut-être jours à l'occasion de leur
faire quand il ya comme ça des
actualités un petit peu plus brûlante
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire ce
que vous en avez pensé dans les
commentaires si ce type de format vous
plaît et puis je vous retrouverai toute
façon très bientôt pour des nouvelles
vidéos dans un format plus classique
voilà merci à bientôt